Every year, the Academy
presents Awards of Merit
in recognition of outstanding
technical advances.
Tonight, we're going
to marvel and honor
the inventions that
have made possible
the magic and the syntax
of motion pictures.
Certainly, no group
in our industry
has unlocked the frontiers
and sought improvement
so consistently as the
scientists and technicians.
And we, even now, are assaulting
new visual and sonic frontiers
of knowledge.
This year's award
winners have made
it possible for our work to
be seen, heard, and preserved
a little better than before.
Without all the contributions
past and present
to the sciences of
filmmaking, there
would simply not be an art
form known as the movies.
For your fine contribution,
the industry salutes you.